a horrific shooting in Nashville leaves
three little kids and three adults dead
the victims were students and teachers
at a Christian School the shooter was a
28 year old woman who identified as a
transgender man we don't know much about
the shooter's motives but that has not
stopped people particularly liberals
from Reading from their perennial script
to blame guns and the Second Amendment
for the evil actions of criminals
more information is coming to light by
the hour and we will get into a lot of
it today
but even if we didn't know anything at
all about this shooter we would know
that the fault could not lie with the
Second Amendment and guns guns which
have been around for about a thousand
years
guns have become more lethal since the
11th century when they were invented
there's no question about that
but guns actually have not become all
that much more lethal they have not
changed all that much over the past
Century machine guns were invented in
the 1880s the Tommy Gun was invented in
1918. those guns are much deadlier than
anything ordinary civilians can get
their hands on today
no over the past 100 years guns have not
changed much at all
our conceptions of mental health on the
other hand and spiritual reality and
political institutions
have all transformed almost beyond
recognition
but very few people in power are willing
to admit that
it's much easier to point fingers
implausibly at the NRA or whatever much
easier and much more dangerous
our Reckless and negligent rulers get
off the hook
the root causes of our social rot remain
unaddressed
and we all just wait for the next
predictable tragedy I'm Michael
knowlesis the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show we have a lot
to get to a lot of
viral video reaction of all of these
social ills that we're talking about the
of isolation the the collapse of the
family and the political order and of
course this gender issue that this this
social
Mania that it that is being encouraged
by some of the most powerful people in
the country first though what do we know
about this shooting
uh the the police chief came out
yesterday some hours after the shooting
which is right here I mean we daily wire
is in Nashville Nashville's not a very
big town and so obviously we were
tracking this very very closely here
here's what the police chief had to say
our investigations tell us that she was
a former student at the school I don't
know what grade she's attended or grades
but we do uh firmly believe she was the
student there
she does uh I didn't identify as
transient yes no motive at this point I
haven't even discovered in the apartment
or house no we have a Manifesto we have
some writings that we're going over that
pertain to this day the actual incident
we have a map drawn out of how this was
all going to take place there's right
now a theory of that's that we may be
able to talk about later but it's not
confirmed and so we'll we'll put that
out as soon as we can
is there any reason to believe that how
she identifies
I'm sorry I'm not someone's Michael I
didn't hear you say that again sir is
there any reason to believe that how she
identifies is
emotive for targeting
school we can give you that at a later
time there is uh some Theory to that
we're investigating all the leads and
once we know exactly we will let you
know so there you have it
you never want to jump to conclusions in
any of these tragedies there's so many
especially the libs but but everybody
feels some impulse to react to any
tragic political event and impose their
political Vision on it so the libs
always do this with the guns totally
implausibly and but the conservatives
here when they heard that it was a woman
or was it a man or it was this name or
was that name daily wire has a rule
generally which is we don't name
Shooters in these situations because we
don't want to give them glory and we
don't want to encourage others there is
an exception to that rule in this case
because the name and the way that naming
works is actually a central part of this
story when the news first broke we were
told it was a young woman then we were
told it was a young man then we were
told it was a person named Audrey then
we were told it was a person named Aiden
and it became clear very very quickly
that this is a transgender identifying
person so what does a transgender
identifying person mean does that mean a
man who's pretending to be a woman does
that mean a woman pretending to be a man
does that mean a woman who's pumped full
of testosterone does that mean a woman
who just says that she's we just we just
didn't know it's it's now become clear
that obviously this person had lots of
identity problems and the police chief
is saying yes one of the theories here
that we're pursuing that seems quite
plausible if not likely is that
transgender identity was a motivating
factor here so so the police chief then
goes on for what we know we know that
they're
this was targeted at this Christian
School we know that this person attended
the Christian school but must have
attended that Christian School like 20
years ago she's 28 years old what else
do we know
it was
extreme
don't know any history of mental illness
at this time put a pause right there
we're not allowed to say anything on
YouTube anymore let's just recount what
what the police chief said the police
chief said this is a woman who thinks
that she's a man
followed by yeah we have no evidence of
mental illness at this time
hmm
not quite sure how to make sense of
those two statements next to one another
keep going the investigation is ongoing
and I'm sorry she identifies a
transgender man or woman as a woman
[Music]
only school that was targeted
I I assume the police chief just being a
normal person just misspoke here because
this issue is so Preposterous but the
question was is this a transgender man
or a transgender woman and
what's confusing about this statement is
if if you're a transgender man that
means you're really a woman and if
you're a transgender transgender woman
that means you're really a man so he
answered he said this person identifies
as a transgender woman which would mean
that she's really a man but uh it would
appear from all the available evidence
no she's really a woman who who
identified as a man keep going
it was the only school that was targeted
there was another location that was
mentioned but because of a threat
assessment by the suspect too much
security they decided not to in that
area was here in Nashville so we're
continuing with that investigation as
well
so this last part not surprising at all
these these would-be shooters always
look for soft targets so if there's a
location where people are armed where
there's a reasonable exploitation that
people might be armed where there's
Professional Security
you're just not going to look at those
places if you're attempting to commit
one of these atrocities
so there was another location there's a
Manifesto we don't have any of that yet
we'll stay tuned
what are the common threads here people
people are saying this is so unusual
because the shooters are usually these
lonely white guys School shooters
and it's a little more complicated than
that if you include
Gang Related school shootings or if you
but but there are common threads here
and I I never really thought the common
threads are
it's white people or it's boys or it's
this or it's that what are the common
threads
history of mental illness
common threads are social isolation
common threads are uh psychiatric drugs
in many cases not in all cases obviously
but in many cases
the common threads are
broken families we don't know anything
about this woman's family now Maybe This
Woman's family is totally fine we just
don't know
and this happens again and again and
again this happened not that long ago a
Colorado also transgender identifying
teenager shot up a Denver area Charter
School
pretty recently left one student dead
and ate others wounded and the the
Curious timing of this attack is that it
coincides within a few days of a planned
National event called the trans day of
Vengeance according to a national group
contacted at our rights DC April 1st
will be the trans day of Vengeance to
stop the trans-genocide allegedly what
is the transgenocide a hallucination of
people who don't have a very good grip
on reality what is the trans genocide
quote unquote the transgenocide is a
fable made up by Disturbed people to
justify violence against conservatives
and Christians and normal people who
understand that men and women are
different and don't think that we should
let men enter into the women's locker
room and strip down naked so the trans
day of vengeance is supposed to take
place in Washington D.C though some of
the people who are supporting this have
suggested that the trans day of engines
take place outside of daily wire
headquarters
take place in Nashville
the group is run not just by completely
Fringe lunatics
well they might also be Fringe lunatics
but some of them have had mainstream
jobs the group is run in part by a
former Democrat staffer
Beau balotti the trans National
recruitment directory is a former
staffer for Virginia Democrats they've
raised money specifically for firearms
training they've called for direct
action in Nashville trans day of
Vengeance not the trans day of Justice
not the day of justice for everybody
Justice is when you give to people that
which they deserve vengeance is not that
vengeance is when you personally take
retribution for a personal slight
perceived or otherwise
and it reminds me of an old proverb that
people variously attribute to all sorts
of thinkers and no one really seems to
know where the proverb comes from but
it's a good one
that is
when you set out for vengeance
dig two graves
dig two graves dig a grave for the
person you want to get Vengeance on and
dig a grave for yourself because that's
how it's going to turn out
certainly how it turned out yesterday
that's how it always turns out though in
the long run
because either the Quest for vengeance
to aggrieve to to
get retribution for a slight real or
perceived will either result in you
being killed or being jailed or it will
result in the destruction of your soul
because
vengeance is mine saith the Lord so do
not take vengeance
is from Deuteronomy this is from letter
of Saint Paul
do not take Vengeance we want to take
Vengeance all the time
and
we we can't do that
we can't do that because it's very bad
for our souls it's very bad for society
we have a civil authority to exact
Justice and people feel really Justified
in
their own personal Vengeance and they
feel really angry Jeffrey Marsh who is
this a transgender identifying uh social
media person who who speaks directly to
children and asks little children to
message him so they can talk about sex
together Jeffrey Marsh said that
transgender identifying people should be
really angry channel that anger
everybody should be really angry you
only hear this
from Disturbed people generally on the
left if you are channeling your anger
not your sense of justice not your
political action to transform the Civil
authority to it enact Justice in a more
perfect way but if you're saying we're
going to go out there when you get
Vengeance you're almost certainly on the
wrong side of things
line from my friend Andrew Cleveland who
says that anger is the devil's cocaine
and it is
and it is and what what do we know about
all of this
we don't know the specific
drugs that this person may or may not
have been on we don't know the
psychiatric help that this person may or
may not almost certainly did not receive
we do not know the nature of the
person's family or Community or
hatred of Christianity perhaps if it's
targeting a Christian School we don't
know any of that
we do know that this stuff is demonic we
do know that
because we strive
against not flesh and blood but against
principalities and powers and spiritual
wickedness in high places and
when ideas
pervade the culture
that
convince you to deny reality and to
pursue fantasy and the deeper one to
that you pursue fantasy the more Angry
you should become and you will become
because when we live according to lies
we become very frustrated because the
reality doesn't match up with what's in
our minds
that is demonic
that's all
that's all that is
speaking of political violence a lot a
lot more of it even outside of Nashville
a staffer for Rand Paul was stabbed and
almost killed in broad daylight in
Washington D.C this after Rand Paul was
stabbed and almost killed at his home by
his neighbor
the Metro Police Department said that
the Rand Paul staffer an adult male was
stabbed multiple times and treated at a
hospital for life-threatening injuries
court documents show the victim told the
detective at the hospital
he didn't know the suspect and did not
did not have any demands made of him
before the attack
we have been told relentlessly for the
past three years that the American left
is under assault and the American left
is representative of our sacred
democracy the temples of which have been
under attack by the right-wing
terrorists And yet when I when I think
of the political violence in recent
years I'm not saying all of it comes
from the left but the vast vast majority
of it comes from the left and of all the
mainstream political violence all of it
comes from virtually all of it comes
from the left
when I think of the attack on Rand Paul
when I think of Steve scalise almost
being killed I think Rand Paul was at
that game too uh when I when I think of
the attack now on this staffer when I
think of the near assassination of Brett
Kavanaugh when I think of the illegal
protests outside the Supreme Court
Justices houses which were permitted and
even encouraged by the ruling class in
D.C
when I think of Hillary Clinton saying
you can't be civil with Republicans when
I think of Maxine Waters saying that
when you see Republicans in the street
you need to push back on them you need
to go to their homes where their
children sleep and say you're not wanted
here when I think of Kamala Harris
bailing criminals out of prison the
rioters from the George Floyd riots and
she raised money to bail them out of
prison when I think of staffers for Joe
Biden doing the same thing not bailing
out peaceful protesters bailing out the
criminals and on and on I think of Ted
Cruz getting chased out of restaurants I
think I think of Chuck Schumer standing
outside the Supreme Court saying we're
coming for you Brett Kavanaugh we're
coming for you justice Gorsuch
that's well you're gonna feel the wrath
that's that's what I that's what I think
of
it's almost all from the left and why do
I bring this up not just to hit the left
not just to
put a mirror up to the left and show
them
the the wickedness that is the
consequence of of their ideas not just
their ideas about how to govern one
policy or another but they're broader
political ideas that that normalize and
encourage Vengeance and violence and
incoherence and unreality but
but then I bring it up because
[Music]
very often we can deceive ourselves we
are constantly deceived because the
imagination of man's heart is evil from
the beginning and so we we it is very
often in the moments of what we perceive
to be our most righteous indignation
that we are most liable to go wrong
the people who are behind the trans day
of Vengeance the people who are
encouraging this kind of political
violence I am certain that they are
convinced in their they've convinced
themselves that they are totally
justified in anything that they do
they've convinced themselves that
right-wingers are trying to commit a
genocide against them they're basing
that on nothing they're basing that on
either lies from the media or their own
their own fantasies a fever dream that
they had based on absolutely no reality
whatsoever but they've convinced
themselves of that and they're they're
they feel that righteous anger and the
devil just loves that
the devil just loves that delusion when
I was thinking about how to cover this
story especially that it's so close to
home Nashville is a very small town
everybody knows everybody
I I I know we were having some
discussions about you know
what one is feeling and I said I know
you're probably feeling righteous
indignation I said I'm not feeling
righteous indignation exactly
I mean I'm it's I'm terribly sad
I'm furious at Injustice
but
I I
it was all just so predictable
it's all just so predictable I guess
that's where my sort of resignation
comes in on all of this
because what's going to happen now is
the libs are going to talk about guns
for a little bit that's probably not
going to go anywhere they're going to
try to ignore
all of the inconvenient facts about this
shooting then they'll move on and
they'll find a more convenient shooting
and then they'll talk about guns again
guns have nothing to do with this have
absolutely nothing to do with this guns
have not changed one bit in the last
sentence you know what how guns have
changed the the design of some of the
rifles have changed a little bit the
maybe some of the rifles are even a
little bit easier to use now
but The lethality of of weapons has not
changed at all it's in fact
the most lethal weapons are harder to
get now when gangsters were using tommy
guns back in the early 20th century that
was a hell of a lot more lethal than
whatever rifle you can go by at Walmart
today the guns
have not really changed they certainly
haven't become
all that much more dangerous if at all
what has changed is the fact that we
call
Insanity sanity and we call truth
falsehood and we call good evil and we
call Beauty ugliness and we deny our
political institutions we call our
political institutions they're rotten we
say that they shouldn't serve the common
good they should serve private factions
and private interest we say that the
fundamental political institution is not
real but is totally socially constructed
we can redefine it into whatever we want
we say that there's no such thing as as
Heaven or Hell there's no such thing as
God there's no ultimate meaning in
society human beings are not for
anything in particular
is it any Wonder
that people go crazy
of
DC politics
back to the 2024 campaign president
Trump
has just announced
at least a surrogate for president Trump
has anonymously announced that he will
Blacklist
anyone
who works for Ron DeSantis
this is being reported by regular
politics which is right wing it's center
right at least
they've said that anyone
who has worked on tour to promote the
governor's new number one best-selling
book
the courage to be free Florida's
blueprint for America's Revival
or who works on any potential
presidential campaign
as Ron DeSantis is already obviously
running for president
uh will not be able to work for Trump's
campaign or in the Trump White House
The Source close to Trump
said anonymously it's a time for
choosing if you work for Rhonda
Sanders's presidential race you will not
work for the Trump campaign or in the
Trump White House
Trump has to put this pressure on right
now because this has
become at least for now a two-man race
the original play and the original
operating strategy was that Trump would
announce that would clear the field he
would be the nominee they'd move on when
it started to look dubious that that
would happen you saw Trump move up the
moment of his announcement
so now two years before the race that
still did not discourage people from
running
Nikki Haley announced she would run
Vivek ramaswamy and now she would run
Tim Scott's making noises Mike Pence is
making noises a number of other people
are making noises and obviously Ron
DeSantis is is the number two candidate
so Trump has to threaten to blackball
these people because if he can kneecap
around DeSantis then he for all intents
and purposes has the nomination and he
has to show consequences for disloyalty
that that's what he's riding on I told
you yesterday I think that right now
Trump is Far and Away the favorite to
win the nomination now it's not to say
DeSantis couldn't win the nomination but
right now even with all of the support
that DeSantis is getting Trump remains
in the lead and he's been bolstered by
one his trip to East Palestine Ohio that
reminded people of a difference between
Trump and the other candidates which is
Trump does really well on the trail with
Ordinary People Trump does really really
well talking about Rust Belt issues he
has in the field a unique credibility on
those issues and then two the fact that
the libs are trying to arrest Trump
it has helped him it's helped him in the
polls even the Democrats admit it's
helped him in the polls it's
distinguished him from the rest of the
field as well where rightly or wrongly
many Republicans have concluded okay if
the libs want to arrest this guy if the
libs are so hell-bent on this guy not
running for president again he must be
our guy
and so he's feeling
he's feeling emboldened and even
liberals now
even the liberal news media are turning
on the brag case this New York DA's
potential indictment of trump because
they're seeing what it's doing to the
poll numbers
we just heard all eyes are on the
Manhattan D.A this week but the case
seems to hinge on a legal Theory that's
never really been used in New York how
risky is this look it's risky for a
number of reasons the the new theory is
in getting it from the misdemeanor to
the felony they're kind of Jerry rigging
it to some degree and the reason that
that's novel and it's difficult it
hasn't been quite done exactly in this
way before but there's also another
Factor here which is this isn't just a
misdemeanor case that they're trying to
get into a felony it's also a
seven-year-old case it's also a case
that two other sets of prosecutors the
previous D.A and the federal prosecutors
decided not to move forward with so you
know when people say to me sometimes
well this had been me I would have been
prosecuted for sure my response is if
this had been you I don't know that
seven years later they would have
Revisited this misdemeanor and tried to
turn it into a felony so it is a
challenging legal Theory they may be
able to do it but but there are problems
here thank you thank you Dan Abrams of
ABC for saying what the conservatives
have known from the very beginning and
that the liberal media were trying to
straight face deny which is this case is
absurd they are trying to jerry-rig a
seven-year-old maybe misdemeanor
and turn that into a presidential
campaign denying
felony all those years later
by the way I don't think it's even a
misdemeanor I think even that would
probably fail in court
but Dan Abrams is saying look they're
Jerry rigging this thing it's it's
ridiculous it's absurd so why are the
liberal media attorney on this this is
Network news this is a major Network
news anchor on ABC why I suspect it's
because the liberal media are watching
the polls
thinking I'll shoot
we were Wiley Coyote man we had that
road runner we were so close the walls
were closing in on Trump we had him now
we had him now and what happened the
second we almost got him his poll
numbers went up shoot abort abort
get it stop it Alvin Bragg get get down
what are you doing idiot you're helping
Trump win
so now Trump is embolden he hits the
campaign Trail for some of his first
real big campaign rallies since he
announced and who's he going after
you know who he's going after
he's gone after DeSantis
I'm a loyalist and and when a man comes
to me tears in his eyes
he said almost nothing in the polls and
he's fighting somebody that's at 42 and
he's got almost 30 million dollars in
the bank he said almost nothing he's got
no cash
and I said I can't give you an
endorsement there's no way you can win
you're dead
but he fought a little bit like 150 he
was certainly know Jim Jordan that I can
tell you he forwarded a little bit just
a little bit on impeachment hoax number
one impeachment hooks number two meaning
on television because I didn't know him
very well but I saw him so he came and
he really wanted I said you can't win
can you how do you can win sir if you
endorsed me I'll win please please sir
endorse me
and I said all right let's give it a
shot because honestly the secretary of
agriculture Adam Putnam good man but I
never met him I didn't know him so I
don't feel guilty about it you know if
you don't know somebody I wish I knew
him actually you want another tooth I
wouldn't have done this I wish I knew
him now man I would have endorsed that
guy knowing now that DeSantis is running
against me a lot of people are saying
can't Trump lay off DeSantis
can't why can't Trump lay off DeSantis
this is ridiculous he should just focus
on bite he's got to lay off to Santa's
no he can't lay off DeSantis they're
running against each other for the
presidential nomination
it's not it's no knock on DeSantis it's
just they're running against each other
I know DeSantis hasn't declared but he's
obviously running for president
and
so you say well DeSantis is taking the
high road almost entirely he's ignoring
Trump's attacks
yeah that's his strategy
that's how he's going to beat Trump
and Trump's strategy is to relentlessly
attack DeSantis that's how he's going to
beat DeSantis
that's politics yeah that's what they
have they're running against each other
only one of them is going to get the
nomination it's a lesson two putting
aside Trump into Sanderson even the 2024
race for a second it's a lesson two
be careful who you help in politics
you got to make sure they're on your
team man because if you make him if you
if you make a person a little too strong
and then that person decides to
challenge you at a certain point
you're gonna have basically nobody to
blame but yourself for helping him this
was an issue with Jeb Jeb and Marco
Rubio in 2016.
Jeb helped make Marco Rubio and Rubio
ran against Jeb Jeb was very upset Jeb
said this is disloyal and Jeb finally
started attacking Marco Rubio but it
didn't work because he's Jeb and so
Marco turns to Jeb and he says you're
you're only attacking me now because
someone convinced you that the only way
to help yourself is to attack me but it
looks ridiculous man come on you help
make me and now I'm going to come up
that's that's the same Dynamic that's at
play here in
2024. now my favorite comment yesterday
is from cool Papa J Magic
who says cool Papa J Magic by the way
has appeared on the favorite comments
many many times and he said what the
conservatives need to realize is that
we've already lost we are not trying to
save we're trying to recapture we have
to remoralize our great men of the West
that's true we're not exactly preserving
I mean there's some things we're still
preserving but
now we're trying to recover something
we're on we're on a mission of recovery
right now and uh the sooner we get that
thinking into our head the uh the sooner
we'll we'll have a vision uh and the
courage to pursue that Vision to reclaim
our cultural inheritance okay
this video it's going viral many of such
videos going viral of a trans man which
is to say a woman
uh complaining that she is being
misgendered and usually when we see
these videos and conservatives play
these videos all the time we just kind
of make fun of the people and we say oh
you know come on you know yeah no one's
calling you by this fantasy
that actually wasn't my reaction maybe
it's because this is a woman who's
pretending to be a man that wasn't my
reaction first time I saw this video
being trans is so hard and so exhausting
like I have been misgendered all day
every single interaction conversation
everything
it's Miss Derek from the beginning day
to now just sick of it I'm sick of
correcting people who won't listen I'm
and I'm sick of people not seeing me I'm
sick of it I'm so sick of it and then
I'm like oh well if I went on tape this
would never happen but I
I just flipped off to believe that
trans people exist
and to look at me and think for a split
second like oh maybe they don't want to
be called a lady maybe maybe that's
so
uh uh this one is some of the videos are
funny
some of the videos with these really
over the top flamboyant people making a
big spectacle of themselves saying why
it's ma'am
what do you mean I'm a
six dude but you didn't
this this woman at the end she pulls
down her shirt and she's got these gash
marks where her breasts used to be where
some lunatic quack doctor chopped off
her healthy organs and This Woman's
crying she says no they just don't they
just misgender me they won't gender me
correct and the only choice I have is to
go on testosterone and then you see the
desperation in her voice she says I
don't want to go on testosterone and of
course she doesn't want to go on
testosterone testosterone I interviewed
Helena kirschner a d transitioner woman
to man to well woman to appearing more
like a man to recognize you she's a
woman again and she said when she was on
testosterone she became very aggressive
she she was impelled to violence and she
said thankfully I turned the violence on
myself I didn't turn the violence on
other people but I turned it on myself
she was cutting herself and all sorts of
great you can see the interviews on my
YouTube channel and so the testosterone
has obviously if you if you inject a
woman with a lot of testosterone it's
gonna have all sorts of crazy effects
and so this woman says I don't want to
go on that I don't but I just why won't
people call me a man I just want to be
commentary and so I I watch a video like
that
you think I can't laugh at that I can't
laugh at that any more than I would
laugh at a sky
[Music]
I'm sure that's terribly painful
the responsibility for that pain lies
with the fact of this Fallen World
people just have problems suffering is
part of life
and a lot of that pain
lies with the teachers who indulge this
the supposed friends who indulge this
certainly the doctors who into quacks
who indulge this they are responsible
for that when you affirm people in lies
and then the people
become very angry and depressed because
the lies they have been told and
affirmed in don't correspond with
reality
the Liars bear a lot of that
responsibility
it's not the it's not the people who
told them the truth that bear that
responsibility it's the Liars who bear
that responsibility
and those Liars have a lot of power you
can't blame that that woman Joe Biden's
telling her that she's a man
but she knows she's not a man deep down
because she lives in reality
and her her imagination has to butt up
against reality as she makes it through
her day her teachers told her she was a
man I'm sure
her whole community did
I know the teachers are saying the stuff
because the teachers now are crying when
Republican
Governors and legislatures say that you
can't teach this stuff in schools that
you're not allowed to have gay porn like
actual gay transgender porn in schools
and the teachers are whining and crying
about this like this Texas teacher if
you've been living under a bubble then
let me tell you the right is trying to
destroy public education you might watch
a video like this you're like this
person's not smart at all wow no they
know what they're doing I'm not bashing
all Charter Schools but charter schools
are a place where problematic things can
happen let me share an experience from a
charter school I interviewed at in Texas
where no I did not take the job I
interviewed for a school librarian
position I was really excited because I
was like okay I think I'm gonna go back
to teaching this year after having my
daughter I was told that the board hand
selects every single book that goes into
the library and you cannot put a single
book into the Library without the
board's approval so I straight up asked
can I teach a book with a gay couple in
it and they were like oh if it's not
explicit that means no that is an
example of what people like approval is
there hold on
so I didn't know what the answer to that
would be and I don't know what the
answer should be
should I guess it maybe depends on the
the age of the students but do you think
that in a in a third grade classroom
students should be taught about these
Divergent Lifestyles I don't think so
shouldn't children be taught men or men
women or women marriage is the union
between a man and a woman that's what
marriage does mean necessarily means and
always has meant and certain people live
in eccentric ways but this is not what
we're going to tell you is normal and
desirable
is it that's what education always was
until
like this year
so I don't know now maybe in
high school or something 11th or 12th
grade
you could see a book where where one
says okay well actually this is this
kind of alternative Arrangement here's
this alternative Arrangement there's
this that and the other thing but
but even regardless let's say that
there's a school district that says no
we want to teach about gay relationships
in the third grade
at the very least there should be some
oversight of that at the very least that
should be up to the parents and the
community in a self-governing society
rather than just one
really passionate activist teacher right
even if you're totally in favor of
teaching kindergarteners about gay
relationships or transgenderism for that
matter what the what the teacher is
complaining about here is not what's
being censored or not being censored
because she said the the board is
allowing the the gay stuff to be taught
in schools as long as it's not
pornographic what she's complaining
about is any oversight at all and what
people on the right want to do with
public education and remember Charter
Schools like that one that I just
described are all government funded we
are paying for that school to accept
yeah it's what's not government funded
because the government is you funded
sir it's the it's the government taking
money from people and then spending that
money in the way that the people desire
at least some of the time and the people
through their elected representatives
are voting for school choice because
they don't want to be locked into these
cartels where teacher unions get to milk
the people and the people I have no say
over how the money spent or how their
kids are educated
so if the schools are failing the
parents can say nope we're pulling our
kid out of there we don't want our kid
being taught
gay porn in the third grade so we're
gonna pull that t that that student out
and put them in this charter school that
we'll give our our student a shot in a
great education and this is especially
true for people who are who are middle
class and lower class
because
the wealthy people always get to send
their kids to whatever schools they want
and the upper class in the middle class
can usually homeschool if they want
but if you're making not a lot of money
and you're in a place with not a lot of
educational options
then your only ticket out is school
choice the teacher says that's really
awful because it's it's government money
no honey it's people money
and we have self-government in the
United States
and the libs always talk about power to
the people until the people don't want
to go along with their programs
we see all these things on Tick Tock but
we might not see these things on Tick
Tock for very long because
the Republicans might ban Tick-Tock and
the Democrats might go along with that
as well U.S House speaker Kevin McCarthy
announced on Sunday that lawmakers would
Advance legislation proposing a
nationwide ban on Tick Tock so not just
on government devices but for everybody
which is fine by me I don't use tick
tock I looked at tick tock
there was one time when Elisa and I
downloaded it because we wanted to see
what all the fuss was about and we're
just sitting there just it was like
crack we're just sort of scrolling like
what recipe is this and why is everybody
dancing uh what is it there's no home
screen you know so you're totally and
then we pulled out we said we got to get
rid of this app this is terrible so I
have a tick tock that is managed by the
daily wire but I don't I don't look at
it so it's fine you banned it for all I
care I don't really mind but
my my trepidation here is
what about Facebook and YouTube and
Google and what about all these other
guys
I get it the tick tock is Chinese and we
don't want our foes overseas
to have some some uh ability to
propagandize to us
but I don't know Tick Tock isn't the
main culprit of banning Donald Trump the
duly elected sitting president when he
was in office
Tick Tock wasn't the the main culprit of
preventing the spread of the hunter
Biden laptop story just days before the
presidential election no I
when when a piece of legislation is
bipartisan support usually that means
it's pretty bad
we that means it's really good no it
means it's I think it's pretty bad
actually because the Democrats get to
tighten their grip on the control of
information around the country and the
Republicans get to saber rattle against
China
but
is is the American Interest really being
served by Banning tick tock
maybe maybe not not totally concerned
speaking of
China you know China engaged in a policy
for decades to reduce the number of
people or to slow the to slow the growth
rate but actually to try to decrease the
number of people overall and it was
pretty heinous it was called the one
child policy well now
every conservative favorite liberal Bill
Maher is pushing that policy on us
we're in the middle of a sixth
Extinction we're losing so many species
and yet there are people and I think
you're one of them who wants us to have
more babies
I don't get this this to connect those
dots for me because I think the problem
with the environment basically is too
many people using too few resources and
people being the we are we're
selfish and we're piggish and we're
sloppy and we're going to use what we
can while we're here so how does more
people solve this problem which seems to
be the number one problem
the number one problem
people
that's what the libs believe that is
what they that's what they believe on
environmentalism that's what they
the the it's what they believe on Family
Planning policy it's what they believe
on political uh stability they think the
problem is people and I those who
promote the idea of overpopulation which
is preposterous the predictions of our
population have just not come true this
was predicted in 1970 in a book by Paul
airlake called population mom he said
within a decade there will be Mass
starvation Mass famine
because of the growth of the population
we need to sterilize people we need
abortion
his policies were implemented in China
and India to to disastrous effect and
then what happened 50 years later the
world population has doubled
malnutritions at an all-time low so it's
not true but I always wonder what these
people who push over population
they say the solution to all of our
social ills is fewer people my my
thought is always okay you first
you for you you think people we got to
get rid of the people okay you first
but I don't really mean that I don't
want these people to kill themselves I
can't help but notice though
that all of their policies have this
strange common commonality
they want abortion which means killing
people they want Mass contraception and
contraception education which means
fewer people will be conceived they want
now the mass castration of large numbers
of children
and adults but children too through the
transgender transition that means fewer
people they want marriage to be
redefined into Oblivion
which means fewer people they want
environmental policies that impel or
compel people to have fewer people
they want
they just
well they tell you they just don't
really like people
that is an ideology
leftism is an ideology
of misanthropy
and
what it
redounds to ultimately is a kind of a
suicide this I I talked about this last
week actually in a in my speech at
Purdue
the liberal project is a project of
Liberation Liberation from all
constraints social norms the moral order
the political order
now of the the fundamental political
institutions like marriage now even
Liberation from the self which is what
the transgender transition is the
transgender transition
is a ritual suicide through which the
transitioning person
figuratively kills himself and then
refers to
himself
as a dead name literally as a dead name
and pretends that he is a new person now
who has been liberated from the
constraints of the self but one cannot
be liberated from the constraints even
of oneself and so what does this we're
down to it we're Downs
to a figurative suicide often a literal
suicide the very same people who are
pushing all of these policies are
pushing for assisted suicide
for the elderly to begin and then for
the mentally ill and for the mentally
deficient and for the depressed people
and it's a suicidal ideology
not
it's not a problem of guns it's not a
problem of self-defense it's not a
problem of
any traditional aspect of our political
order it is a problem of an ideology
that has
steadily taken hold for a very very long
time now that redounds in a political
spiritual and personal death
on that Bleak note we will be moving
into the member block the Nostradamus
member room segmentum we will be
examining some movies that Mr Davies
insists that I check out the rest of the
show continues now you don't want to
miss it become a member use code Knoll
scanner w-les and check out four two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]
oh
foreign